working a retail job is generally less
than ideal most people working retail
jobs have no other choice and they're
simply trying to make ends meet
considering this it's not surprising
that most retail giants have terrible
employee retention with walmart ranking
the bottom 25 of employers
but there is one grocery chain called
heb that retail employees not only love
working at but they never want to leave
in fact heb ranks in the top five
percent in terms of employee retention
and they boast an a plus rating compared
to walmart c minus at heb it's not
uncommon to see employees start off as
card pushers and baggers in high school
who slowly work their way up to cashier
shift manager and store manager by the
time they're in their 40s
you couldn't even pay these guys to
leave as 50 of employees said that they
wouldn't leave heb even if they were
offered a higher paying job
but this isn't too surprising when you
consider that heb is not only one of the
best retail employers but the 10th best
employer in america period that's 21
spots higher than apple so here's how a
retail store became one of the best
places to work in america
taking a look back the story of heb
dates back to the early 1900s to a
couple named charles and florence butt
the family was originally from tennessee
but they decided to move to caribou
texas because charles was suffering from
tuberculosis and they believed that a
drier climate would help his condition
after moving to texas in an effort to
support the family financially florence
began a small grocery store on the
ground floor of their apartment in 1905.
renting the ground floor cost her nine
dollars per month and she used the rest
of her savings which was 60 dollars to
stock the store
initially she sold her grocery items
door to door which was particularly hard
given that many customers were rude and
unforgiving labeling her as a peddler
but as she slowly built up a small group
of loyal customers florence was able to
give up her door-to-door days and stick
to the store
luckily florence had three children and
two stepchildren who could help around
the store in the early days but florence
would end up running the store by
herself as world war 1 rolled around
around the same time her husband charles
senior would pass away in 1915 so
florence was truly on her own for many
years
fortunately two of her children charles
jr and howard would eventually return to
the business
charles jr returned to 1917 and howard
returned 1919 after serving in world war
one for several years charles jr and
howard would leave the grocery store
together but in 1926 charles jr would
also succumb to tuberculosis just like
his father which left the store to
howard and his mother howard attempted
to expand the store by opening three
more locations in the same area but none
of these panned out
it wasn't until howard took a loan for
38 thousand dollars and open stores
outside of kerbel that he found some
success
as for florence she stuck around until
1934 but as she saw that howard had a
good grip on the business she stepped
away from the business but she never
stepped away from the community florence
strongly believed that it was the
community that got her family through
their roughest time and she was
eternally grateful for that so she did
everything she could to give back to the
community she opened the baptist church
in curveball and paid for the pastor's
salary for several years she also never
thought twice to give to those in need
and that brings us into the first core
value that drives employees at heb which
is community service to this day heb is
dedicated to helping every community
they serve
in fact they have so many community
oriented programs that would take hours
to go through all of them so i'll just
come over the most significant ones
starting with supplier diversity
instead of sticking with large big box
suppliers heb goes out of their way to
support local businesses run by women
minorities veterans disabled individuals
and the lgbt community another heb
community program is operation
appreciation heb regularly sends out
care packages to active service members
and they even build houses for veterans
who are injured while on duty another
heb program is hunger relief which
donates absurd amounts of food to food
banks in 2018 alone heb donated 32
million pounds of food to food banks in
texas and mexico which works out to 25
million meals yet another http program
is disaster relief which focuses on
donating money emerging supplies
drinking water and food to victims of
natural disasters all of that is just
scratching the surface of hp's community
involvement
they also have programs related to
sustainability education first
responders diversity and much more and
on top of all of that heb has been
donating five percent of their pre-tax
income to charity for over 80 years
given heb substantial community
involvement heb employees often feel
like they're not just working a job but
that they're truly serving their
community and this has done wonders for
hb's employees satisfaction and spirit
anyway going back to howard he relocated
the headquarters of the business to
harlingen texas in the late 1920s and he
would open the company's first
distribution center in harlingen howard
began a tradition of supporting local
suppliers by opening the harlingen
cannery which featured texas grown
texas-packed food over the next several
years howard opened a handful of stores
across texas in laredo corpus christi
austin and san antonio
these stores were generally about 10 000
square feet on average so much bigger
than the grocery store his mom used to
run but just as everything was
progressing forward a massive hurricane
would destroy the company's distribution
center in 1933 despite suffering a
massive loss himself howard donated food
and water to the disaster victims and
the following year was the first time
that howard would donate five percent of
the company's income to charity with the
establishment of the h.e butt foundation
in 1935 howard changed the name of the
grocery store from cc but grocery to
aichi butt grocery he would eventually
shorten this to heb in 1946
as heb continued to grow howard got his
children howard jr and charles involved
in the business
charles describes that he was working at
the store by the time he was eight and
that he would consistently work friday
afternoons and saturdays throughout his
childhood howard spent a lot of time
trying to convince charles and howard jr
to stay at the business and though he
was successful with charles howard jr
would go on his own path
when they grew up howard jr became a lay
minister while charles went to wharton
business school before returning to the
business
and when howard retired in 1971 charles
took over as president and he's been
president's ceo ever since
to this day heb is a private family
business and they don't have a bunch of
wall street investors gobbling up their
stock
but this doesn't mean that heb is only
owned by the butt family while they
don't want to share heb with wall street
they're more than happy to share the
company with their employees and that
brings us to heb second core principle
which is treating employees like family
given the nature of retail it's quite
difficult to pay high salaries due to
low margins but heb does everything they
can to give their employees the best
benefits and perks they offer great 401k
plans retirement plans and entrance
options they also offer their employees
a 10 discount on all hpv brand products
but by far the coolest perk i think is
their stock compensation plan basically
all heb employees are eligible for stock
compensation regardless of what work
they do
so it's not some sort of elitist
executive thing to receive stock
compensation heb only has three
requirements
you have to be at least 21 years old
work at least one year at heb and you
must put in at least 1 000 hours per
year in other words you must be at least
a part-time employee as long as you take
all these boxes you're eligible to
receive a stock bonus worth 3 of your
annual income plus 100 worth of stock
every year
these types of benefits for retail
employees are basically unheard of
walmart offers a 15 discount on their
stock for their employees up to 1800
but i'm not familiar with any company
that gives their retail employees stock
compensation leave a comment down below
if you know another company that does
this
by giving juicy perks and benefits to
virtually all of their employees heb
makes it clear that they highly value it
and cherish their employees which has
only further cemented their employee
loyalty anyway going back to charles he
opened the company's first limited
assortment store called heb pantry foods
in 1988.
these stores centered on selling basic
groceries for low prices and were
generally much larger than traditional
igbs coming in at 24 000 to 30 000
square feet this quickly became the
bread and butter of the company and is
what most people associate with heb
today
in the early 1990s charles also
experimented with a new style of store
called the central market
central market officially debuted in
1994 and there's only 10 locations but
each of these locations are massive at
coming in at ninety thousand to one
hundred thousand square feet
central market is basically heb's
version of whole foods moving forward
hdb expanded into mexico in 1997 with
the store in monterey as you would guess
their mexican stores support the mexican
economy by sourcing 85 of their
offerings from mexican suppliers
the latest major development coming from
agb is their hdb plus stores which begin
operations in 2005. on top of offering
everything found in regular hebs plus
doors offer a larger baby department
more outdoor supplies more garden
equipment and a larger assortment of
electronic and household items today heb
generates a total of 31.2 billion annual
revenue and they employ over 135 000
employees the bud family is estimated to
be worth 10.7 billion dollars as of
january 2016. but i don't think that
money was ever the family's primary
focus and i think that's played the
secret behind her success florence
didn't start hgb to get super rich she
started it out of desperation to
financially support her family as soon
as the family became financially stable
florence turned her focus onto giving
back and that's how the family has run
the company ever since whether that be
giving back to employees customers or
the community all of their financial
success has simply been a byproduct of
them serving the community to the best
of their ability and i suspect that
charles is a lot more proud of being the
number 7 most approved ceo in the us and
the highest ranked retail ceo on the
list than he is of his 10 billion
fortune have you guys ever worked a
retail job and if so how was your
experience comment that down below
also drop a like if you think walmart
should take notes from heb
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one